the door study this video shows a  participant from a 1998 study by Daniel  Simon's and Daniel Levin watch what  happens as the unsuspecting pedestrian  provides directions the young man on the  Left is one of the experimenters he is  approached the white-haired man and  asked for directions  watch closely as two people carrying a  door passed between them and the first  experimenter is replaced by someone else  like many of the people in the study the  pedestrian was entirely unaware that he  was talking to a different person  approximately 50% of the people  approached in this study didn't notice  when the person they were talking to was  replaced by someone else  this study was among the first to  demonstrate that change blindness can  occur outside of the laboratory this  video is from research by Daniel Simon's  in Daniel 11 and is copyrighted it is  available for use in talks training and  teaching on DVDs from these gog  productions learn more at the invisible  gorilla calm